evil is on board
powerful evil
we call him Dracula
the Demeter
on Charter from Romania to London
shipping private crates
content unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
this year's Commons he's a doctor
dress like a learned man University of
Cambridge I know my way around the boat
our Charter has agreed to pay Wellness
for timely arrival in London
we'll show you the ship
we're not Comfort like this to give the
use clear
[Applause]
something ripped about the animals
on the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship everywhere
evil isn't bored
[Music]
powerful evil
thank you
in night it drinks our blood yes
we call him Dracula
he's coming
did you see the size of that bloody
thing
[Music]
a Zombie Ship which means we will never
leave it the devil is real
God have mercy on us all